[Musique]
les laveuses
comme tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
les gens le col sur leur voiture sur
leur pare chocs fier du champignon les
champignons atomiques pousse partout sur
les tee-shirts les casquettes les
chaussettes
vous pouvez acheter des sweat shirt avec
le champignon des bavoirs pour bébé avec
le champignon atomique mascotte du lycée
de richland est un champignon nucléaire
et ça c'est vraiment fou quand on arrive
pour la première fois à richland ce qui
frappe c'est la relation très
particulière que la ville entretient
avec la bombe atomique
richmond est la ville voisine du
complexe nucléaire d'europe ford
c'est ici qu'on a produit le plutonium
de la banque de nagasaki nous sommes
dans l'ouest des états unis
en plein milieu d'un désert dans l'état
de washington
l'islande est une ville de 45000
habitants où chaque famille a un lien
avec l'industrie du nucléaire
on la surnomme atomique city
[Musique]
en pénétrant dans le lycée de richland
on reste un peu interloqué le champignon
atomique sert de mascotte aux élèves
l'équipe de football s'appelle les
bombers dans la région les bombers sont
réputés imbattable
[Musique]
à
quand je suis devenu le coach de
l'équipe
on m'a demandé ce que j'allais mettre
sur les casques le porter le champignon
atomique sur mon casque quand je jouais
ici je suis j'ai voulu revenir à ce que
je connaissais tout voilà donc remis le
champignon en pensant que c'était une
bonne chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
akon
oui
[Applaudissements]
la plupart des jeunes n'associe plus à
la guerre pour eux c'est la mascotte de
la riche flandre high school
vous savez on en est à la quatrième
génération
mes grands parents mes parents moi ma
fille qui passe par ce qu'il sait c'est
ce qu'ils connaissent personne n'imagine
que cela disparaisse un jour il ya des
professeurs ici qui sont très claires
ils sont contre le champignon atomique
ils n'en sont pas fiers ils respectent
pas un jeu et je respecte leur opinion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
professeur en but a toujours été de ce
fait la façon de penser des élèves je
leur pose des questions complexes
cette controverse en particulier
parfaite pour ça elle les dérange les
écrivent dans leur dissertation
je comprends que ce n'est pas
politiquement correct et je laime quand
même une fille m'a dit c'est dur
monsieur car j'aime tellement symbole il
représente si bien riche flandre
il est fort et quand je regarde les
faits c'est difficile de le défendre
je lui ai répondu eh bien c'est
peut-être la leçon la plus importante
que tu as a prises souvent nous
réagissons avec notre coeur plutôt
quelques poteries et puis rien n'est
jamais vraiment bon mauvais
m
[Musique]
ancien coach des bombers scott était
aussi professeur d'histoire au lycée
durant les années où il a entraîné
l'équipe il avait banni le champignon
des tenues de sport mais pour moi c'est
un symbole qui ne représente rien de
positif
comme partout dans le monde d'ailleurs
excepté al-arich l'inde high school je
suis diplômé de la rich and high school
mais ça m'a toujours mis vraiment mal à
l'aise en même temps ça m'a toujours
tenu à l'écart des honneurs en tant que
coach évidemment écartées de tous leurs
trucs mais il ya des choses plus
importantes dans la vie dans le dos des
vestes
ils ont mis cette énorme champignon
atomique dans lequel ils ont inscrit
atomise laine ou et en tant que
professeur d'histoire c'est vraiment dur
d'accepter ça quand vous savez ce que
signifie atomisent les pas seulement au
niveau de la seconde guerre mondiale
mais dans son sens global
c'est dur de voir une autre génération
se faire en doctrine est sous
l'influencé du champignon c'est vraiment
dur de voir que ça continue
le champignon atomique c'est toute
l'histoire de richland elle commence en
1943 en pleine seconde guerre mondiale
le gouvernement fédéral choisit alors le
désert de benford pour produire du
plutonium
le site est isolé et la rivière
colombien permet de refroidir les
réacteurs
l'épopée industrielle est lancé classé
secret défense
nom de code le projet manhattan on est
devenu le plus gros producteur de
plutonium au monde et tout le système
opérer dans le secret l'isolément et le
privilège qu'on produire des armes
nucléaires en un temps très restreint
c'est une prouesse industrielle et
technologique 50 mille ouvriers en
provenance de tout le pays participe au
projet manhattan dans leur offre des
billets du train d aller simple on leur
promet de bons salaires et des paysages
à couper le souffle les attire par
milliers les baraquements sorte de la
poussière comme un véritable champignons
démographique
[Musique]
progressnow richland aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que les maisons sont bâties
selon les mêmes modèles ce sont en fait
les maisons de l'époque construite pour
loger les salariés
70 ans plus tard l'héritage atomique se
décline sous des formes inattendues mais
on peut se demander si derrière tout ça
il ya une réelle fierté bien est ce une
sorte de folklore nostalgique
c'est le moment d'aller goûter une
atomique pizza avec une plutonium porter
à l'atonie calibre
[Musique]
on a des noms géniaux pour nos bières
half life et verizon atomique amber
plutonium porter internationale plutôt
apple s'amuse bien et dont on évite
d'utiliser des symboles comme la bombe
le champignon atomique on préfère jouer
sur la nostalgie de l'ère atomique et
l'histoire de ce bien il y en a très peu
qui voit ça de manière négative
on a ouvert il ya 15 ans et ces
dernières années c'est devenu de plus en
plus populaires d'utiliser le mot
atomique pour son business
[Musique]
il y en a qui disent ici que si vous
êtes contaminée par les radiations
la meilleure chose à faire est de boire
beaucoup de bière pour purger votre
organisme
c'est pour ça qu'on est ici pour aider
les gens à éliminer leur contamination
radioactive alors buvait atomique à
l'atome c'est le clin d'oeil locale
pourtant l'histoire pourrait prendre une
tournure plus inquiétante pour les
habitants de la ville récemment une
équipe de décontamination a découvert
une fuite radioactive sous un ancien
bâtiment du complexe danford à deux pas
de richland la radioactivité s'élève à
10 fois la dose mortelle
[Musique]
allons voir de plus près à quoi
ressemble nfor nous quittons l'oasis de
richland pour le désert nous entrons
dans une zone nationale sacrifier les
déchets nucléaires sont enterrés ici
le dernier réacteur a cessé de
fonctionner en 1987 à la fin de la
guerre froide depuis le nettoyage du
site est classé priorité nationale par
le gouvernement
and ford est le site le plus contaminé
du monde après tchernobyl m ces produits
ne sont pas stockées dans les meilleures
conditions de sécurité
la grande majorité des déchets n'est
même pas contenue dans des filets qu
mais tout simplement dans le sol et
lorsqu'il pleut qu'il neige ou qu'il
gèle et que le sol est humidifié les
déchets sont entraînés jusqu'à la nappe
phréatique et la nappe phréatique
conduit directement à la rivière et
menacent l'environnement dans mille ans
la concentration de plutonium dans la
nappe phréatique au niveau de la rivière
sera environ 300 fois supérieur à celle
d'aujourd'hui quel endroit est
suffisamment sécurisé pour y mettre ces
déchets pour les prochains temps ni leur
avenir
[Musique]
on pense qu'il faut au moins deux cent
mille ans pour que le plutonium cesse
d'être radioactives alors comment le
stocker en toute sécurité
rainford 14 mille employés travaillent
nuit et jour à cette tâche à haut risque
soit un quart de la population active de
la région
la réserve nucléaire et le pouls
économique de toute cette communauté
le travail doit être accompli c'est une
nécessité
nous devons nettoyer le désastre que
l'on a causé dans la région c'est sans
doute l'un des meilleurs salaires que
l'on peut trouver et j'en ai profité
j'ai élevé cinq enfants ici et j'ai eu
une bonne vie en juillet 2007 lors d'une
intervention technique
[Musique]
il s'est produit une fuite de gaz de
cuisine cuves et je ne savais pas donc
je suis allé jusqu'à la centrale pour
tourner des valves et j'ai traversé les
vapeurs
et les poumons étaient endommagés il
exhale ont dit que j'aurai des séquelles
jusqu'à la fin de mes shows avant d'être
victime
personne n'imagine que c'est si
dangereux mais après avoir été touché
oui ils ouvrent les yeux et deviennent
convaincu de la dangerosité
je crois que pendant longtemps personne
ne voulait croire que les travailleurs
pourraient être touchés on préférait
qu'on sait que nous telle personne était
particulièrement essentielle mais ce
n'est pas le cas les gens sont encore
victimes même depuis mon accident en
2007 il ya eu d'autres opérateurs
touchés et pas forcément de la centrale
à des endroits qui sont supposés être
sûr comme négativement de contrôle où
les tartines par exemple la seule source
d'information vient de là bas et il y a
un discours ambiant qui s'est développée
sur le thème
sécurité sécurité sécurité et même si ce
n'est pas sécurisé on l'entend si
souvent qu'on finit par le croire
de fait beaucoup de travailleurs eux
mêmes
trois discours donc une porte ni masque
ni protection et des collègues qui se
plaignent un peu trop fort ou un peu
trop souvent sont invités à l'affirmer
cheryl aimerait retrouver un job moins
contraignant au sein de canford mais
elle ne suit que des refus selon elle
c'est trop tard elle est passée de
l'autre côté le côté d'une vision
critique n'a jamais vraiment dit qu'on
pourrait perdre son job et on ressent
que si on fait trop de vagues
je n'ai jamais dit comme ça mais n'a pas
menacé mais la perception est que si tu
fait des vagues
les choses pourraient ne pas être aussi
confortable pour toi
[Musique]
à richland remettre en question la
sécurité nucléaire c'est remettre en
question l'avenir de la ville karen ford
a besoin de main d'oeuvre des jeunes si
possible car il aurait une scène
à 27 ans il semble avoir littéralement
plongé son bras dans l'histoire
iconographique de la ville c'est une
sorte d'hommage à chez moi c'est ici
pour toujours et ce quelque chose dont
je pourrais parler toute ma vie et les
gens veulent entendre cette histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cai est un ancien élève de la rich and
high school et travailla and ford son
job vérifier le niveau de radioactivité
avant l'intervention des équipes selon
lui les normes de sécurité sont
impressionnantes et les incidents sont
rares mes grands parents ont travaillé
là bas mes parents ils travaillent
toujours ma petite soeur et moi aussi
et si je reste dans le coin avec j'ai
des mômes ils travailleront sûrement par
là bas non seulement tout le passé de
richland est liée à la bombe
mais en plus les jeunes générations
seront sollicités pour achever la
dépollution
combien d'élèves du lycée de richland se
retrouveront à hanford pour cette
communauté
le nucléaire est une affaire de famille
[Musique]